we're gonna be talking about is llms
which we've all heard of and the
semantic layer and how together they
enable a form of self-serve analytics
and self-serve data that wasn't possible
before
so let me jump in and I'll introduce
myself
so who am I I'm Paul I'm the CTO and
co-founder of zenlitic zenletics a bi
tool so we compete with Tableau looker
power bi all of these sort of bi tools
to make data more accessible to end
users
I've got a master's in data science from
Harvard I live in Denver Colorado moved
there from New York I've worked in data
for a little over seven years mostly
setting up a lot of these Stacks so I've
set up and configured basically all data
warehouses you can think of and pretty
much all bi tools you can think of so
I've got a lot of experience in how
these things go wrong firsthand because
the sort of default stance of doing
anything data is that it's probably
going to go wrong
I'm also very into rock climbing which
is what spurred the move from New York
to Denver
so let's dive in if we're going to talk
about self-serve we've got to ask what
is a data scientist's job because when
you think about what is sort of
self-serve for a non-technical person
that is the inverse that is what
isn't a data scientist job and that is
what we're going to be looking at for
self-serve self-service things that end
users and consumers of the data are able
to get for themselves without the help
of a of a technical person
and but the thing is that that's not
necessarily a single
thing a single ability that changes and
it changes based on the underlying
technology that enables different forms
and different
modalities of self-serve different
abilities that weren't possible before
so if we think about you know what you
can consider self-serve maybe back in
the day looking at you know static
dashboards is self-serve in a sense if
you're looking at you know Revenue over
time in some big olap Cube back in 2005
that self-serve in the sense you're not
messaging someone to get that data it's
maybe not self-serve and the way we
think about it but self-serve itself is
this spectrum that sort of increases
capabilities continuously based on the
power of the underlying technology
so then after these you know view
dashboards you have something like
Tableau where instead of just being able
to view this sort of cube of a dashboard
you can actually filter it you can edit
it maybe you can change a few things
Group by something
um you know actually have a little bit
of interactivity so that that enables
another layer of self-serve if you are
able to you know go in and add a filter
that you need or you know change
something from monthly to weekly that's
fewer and fewer emails that end up going
to the data team
but then technology changes and it
advances and you get tools like
snowflake which enable products like
looker where instead of just being able
to be limited to okay we've got some
filters on this dashboard we've got
maybe you know some some widgets we can
change on the dashboard you're able to
explore from here on a dashboard you're
able to go and actually take some
content on that dashboard and iterate on
it maybe one or two steps if you're not
a technical user for technical People
Like Us these interfaces might be a
little bit straightforward but for
people who are not as technical they're
they're still pretty hard
so then the question is well what's the
next what's the next step and what's the
next major
major change in terms of Technology
that's going to allow self-serve to move
forward
so that major change of Technology
allows you to explore anywhere where you
no longer have to know which explorer
something's in which table something's
in which folder something's in
um you know you no longer have to figure
out like what exactly the terminology is
that you're talking about you can ask a
question and be able to get a competent
answer that actually answers it
and that is something that you need the
intelligence of a large language model
to be able to do so we've all heard of
large language models so it's been a lot
of time talking about what they can do
they're they're pretty cool well you
know I mean just just with the release
of gpt4 the the amount of hype around
these things is just at an absolute fee
for pitch now
um the you know Twitter verse basically
hangs on every like open AI release you
know they release chat GPT and it's
compared to the iPhone moment they
repeat release
plugins and it's compared to the App
Store
um it's absolutely groundbreaking
technology and that's you know apparent
to everyone
it's absolutely incredible what what
they can do and what those products are
capable of but
it's actually not good enough
and okay so why isn't it good enough
it's it's a pretty impressive product
we've all seen it it's amazing
um because when you get inside a
business you have problems like these do
you use process that or create that for
recognizing Revenue
is net revenue net of refunds or just of
discounts
why is the customer table fan out when I
join on customer ID seems obvious that
that should be the primary key
are active users based on that user
status field or is that you know some
like interactions logins things like
that
so in the problem and the kicker is that
these are real world examples of real
world problems that I've had as a human
doing data setting people up and seeing
exactly this you know I've seen
problems translating data because people
are looking at the wrong dates for
revenue and they're unable to match
numbers that they need to match I've
seen different basically as many
different definitions of net revenue as
you have companies because companies
have different needs they have different
definitions that serve them in different
ways so these definitions are not the
same across companies and it's really
important that they stay consistent
inside of a company otherwise you have a
lot of Chaos
and you know this customer table example
like I've seen customer tables where
people decide to add in email leads that
have no customer ID that fans out all
these joins Downstream
um this stuff this stuff happens and
it's just what data looks like in a lot
of organizations
um you like what defines as an active
user isn't just you know
a field or a level of logins like that
that definition can actually change
business needs change what it means to
be active can actually change and this
stuff isn't
generalized it's not
you can't just take generally what does
it mean to be active and apply that to
any specific business businesses have
real needs that need to be unique and
specific to them
and the the core Point here is that even
a human with experience in this area
can't do this without context on the
business without going in and doing the
work and figuring out how this stuff is
defined figuring out you know the way
that these definitions work the way that
the tables work the nuances and the sort
of tribal knowledge that lives inside of
these companies so even though llms are
really really powerful and really
impressive technology if they don't have
that business context they're just not
going to be able to make the right
decisions and be able to give people
reliable metrics that they can actually
trust
so at the end of the day you can't trust
them to pull data and you can't trust
them because
basically data is hard they make
generalizations they take
um you know what sort of across their
whole training data means revenue or net
revenue or active users and that might
not be what it is for your business and
mistakes here aren't just you know oh it
you know said something silly in that
poem are it didn't understand what you
know that idiom is like this is board
reporting this is a big deal people can
get sued over wrong numbers here and
it's really really critical that this is
data that you can trust and part of what
that means is that an end user isn't
going to use a tool no matter how easy
it is to use if there's some chance that
they will just get a wrong number that
comes back to them because that sort of
defeats the whole purpose of of having
the tool in the first place
and what that means at its core is that
text to SQL won't cut it for analytics
because no matter how good you are at
generating that SQL unless you have the
context on the business and like exactly
how everything is defined for the
business you're gonna occasionally do
wrong stuff and you're you might use a
fine definition but that's not the one
that the company uses and that's a big
deal that's you know those the error is
there are a very big problem
so how do you fix that problem how do
you give an llm the context for it to be
able to make the right decisions you
have to marry it to the business's
context you have to marry it to the
semantic layer so that you actually have
the context and you can take advantage
of what the llms are good at because
what the llms are good at is
comprehension they can understand a
person's intent and distill that into a
set of actions and a response that they
can take that is useful and informative
for that person so they're core skill
their core kind of value prop is
comprehension
and then so we get into the context part
to the semantic layer so I'll give a
quick little overview of what a semantic
layer is
uh the semantic layer is just think of
it like definitions so that can be a
definition of a metric like how you
define a net revenue or how you define
you know a discount a gross revenue a
churn an active user things like that
those can be Dimensions that use to
slice by things that includes you know
acronyms things that are internal to
your company that maybe don't make a lot
of sense anymore but they've always been
done like that so you need to continue
to have that naming
um that stuff's important how joins work
how to properly join tables together
even if you have weird nulls in certain
cases like that's just how data looks in
most companies you have to be able to
handle that and the semantic layer gives
you the ability to encode that
information in something that is
governed in git that lets you provide
that information to any Downstream
service that's going to generate SQL so
the core value prop of a semantic layer
then is correctness
so
whereas with L alums we had
comprehension with semantic layers we
have correctness the semantic layer can
guarantee that every time you calculate
you know active users every time you
calculate churn no matter what you
joined in to do that or what you
um sliced by or what you filtered by
you're going to use the same exact
definition every time and you can trust
that that number is going to be
calculated correctly
So at their core what semantic layers do
is they give you correctness
and semantic layers really are necessary
for Effective self-serve even without
talking about llms I'm just going to
talk about a few examples that again
I've seen out in the wild of what this
sort of progression and what this looks
like without a semantic layer so you
know there are real companies a lot of
the people who use data at these
companies who have some sort of bi
service
that they go and download a CSV from and
then they go to Shopify or recharge or
something and download a CSV from there
and do all these vlookups in Excel and
it takes them 20 hours a week to get
data that a lot of the times there's
some small error in and it ends up being
kind of wrong and that's just sort of
how how it works in a lot of
organizations
or you have the sort of dashboard sprawl
where you've got these you know nine
different partially outdated definitions
of churn or active users or something
like that
and those outdated definitions
some of them might be right some of them
might be wrong it's really unclear to
any of the people actually using the bi
tool which one's right which one's wrong
so that still ends up being an email to
somebody because you can't pick the
wrong one
um or even if you have a technical team
even if you have people who are able to
write SQL they end up writing ad hocs
equal to answer basically every question
because there's no framework in place
that lets them be able to say oh hey
I've got you know this answer over here
based on these two tables
someone just asked me to join in you
know the fourth table over there a few
tables away there's no way to do that
easily so you just have to write the SQL
yourself and that process not only is it
excruciatingly difficult but it just
takes a really long time and it's Error
prone you can forget that one little
rule that you needed to do on that join
and all of a sudden things are wrong
so it's just really easy to make
mistakes here and it's not like any of
the teams that are doing this or
slacking off like they're working really
hard like you have to work really hard
to be able to to fill all of these
requests It's just tough
um so then the question is like what is
what does good look like
so to not pick on but to promote like a
specific example uh Warby Parker is
great at data
um they make great glasses and they're
very good at data so what makes them
really good though is that they spend
um pretty much all of their data teams
time building and refining their
semantic layer so instead of you know
answering all these questions and sort
of putting a lot of energy into
answering these ad-hoc questions they go
in and they spend a lot of energy
defining these joins properly defining
these metrics properly working with
stakeholders to make sure that they have
a consistent definitions for these
metrics and that's a different kind of
work it still takes work but their data
team overall spends a lot less time
answering these ad-hoc questions than a
lot of these other companies
but that's not that's not it you can't
fully get to self-serve even with a
best-in-class semantic layer and a top
tier data team that's you know working
really hard to make this semantic layer
polished and usable because at the end
of the day there is you need to be able
to merge these results together you know
end users don't know where things are if
they're asking a question about you know
marketing spend or something like that
and then they have a question about
acquisition those might not actually be
near each other in terms of the same
Explorer the same table and then they
can't figure out how to get to them it's
just very hard for end users to be able
to navigate these interfaces
and you see that just in the adoption
rates of pretty much all bi tools it's
just really hard to to get end users to
actually use these tools instead of just
email someone because that's the kind of
default and they can trust that if they
email someone who has contacts with the
business they're going to be able to
give them the right answer
so even with a good semantic layer it's
still really hard to be able to make
self-serve work and that's where you get
the meme that self-serve is a myth that
it's just not going to work that there's
no way that you know for until the end
of time we will be emailing data teams
asking them you know about Revenue
return numbers in the last week so you
know we even see here
um from our favorite birds.csv that
we've got you know six like two-thirds
um think that we'll have self-driving
cars before we have self-serve Analytics
so I think I think I think we might be
wrong we'll see about that
um
so then going back to sort of where we
are now so we've got these two tools
we've got comprehension
from llms
we've got correctness from the semantic
layer
and when we marry them we have context
so and that context is is really where
the magic happens like you're able to
take the ability that The llms Have and
combine it with the ability that the
semantic layers have and
um when you combine those you can
actually take the business's context
your acronyms your idiosyncrasies the
you know long weird descriptions that
you need to describe what's going on and
make all of that available as context so
you're effectively able to make an llm a
high context analyst that effectively
works on behalf of your end users
instead of responding in days due to a
very long queue it's responding in
seconds
and that's pretty game changing and
we're going to look at a little bit of
how these two complement each other so
the semantic layer fixes the llm's
hallucination problem so we've all seen
you know tons of examples including the
little silly one I have up here 413
divided by 7 is actually 59 with no
remainder and that's sort of a silly
example you know it's it's sort of funny
that it got it wrong
if the llms are coming up with SQL and
they get something wrong like that that
might not even be super obvious to begin
with the results can be catastrophic it
can calculate a funnel wrong it can you
know calculate Revenue wrong and if it
does these things and gives a wrong
answer to someone like a CEO or someone
like that
you know you have board reporting at
stake it's a really big deal to get
these things wrong so Hallucination is
is not a joke it's not like something
that a human's gonna then correct if
you're generating SQL playing and
running it on the database it's it's
really dangerous even with a even with a
powerful llm unless you join it with the
correctness of the semantic layer
and then conversely the llm interface
which literally everyone knows how to
use is uh what can fix the semantic
layer is complexity semantic layers are
really powerful you have you know these
definitions of joins that cover
potentially hundreds of tables and you
know hundreds or thousands of metrics
and they can get really complicated it's
hard in any sort of traditional UI to be
able to Surf
um that huge quantity of content there
with an llm you have effectively an
analyst who has context on all of those
and can just answer the questions
and then the combination of those is
that self-serve becomes like talking to
a data scientist you can actually just
ask someone in the same way that you
know you've all probably gotten emails
asking about various data questions
um instead of those emails going to you
that same email goes to an llm that has
actually all that huge amount of context
on the business and at these larger
scale businesses like a Warby or
something the the quantity of that
context just becomes so great that even
if you're you know you've worked at the
company for years it's hard for you to
keep all of that in your head at the
same time
um you know you're going to make a
mistake it's a lot easier for an llm to
keep you know thousands of metrics in
its head effectively at the same time
than it is even for for you as a human
so it's a really natural interface it's
an interface where you don't have to
when you get started
know you know exactly what you're
looking for you can kind of ask some
probing questions
you don't have to know where things are
you don't have to care that you know to
get what you want you've gotta you know
run two queries and then merge them that
just kind of happens so it makes it
takes a whole new
um level of self-serve and makes that
level available when it wasn't before
so now we're going to look at a little
demo that we have of zenletic and this
is very very early Innings of what's
possible with these llms
so
let's see what we've got here
so like I was saying you don't have to
have perfect context on what
um
on what you can ask where things are you
can just sort of ask things and be sort
of guided in the right direction
and importantly you can ask these
questions iteratively so you don't have
to have you know we've all seen like SQL
generators that are basically like you
know show me you know Revenue
with you know the state is California
it's effectively SQL that just you know
isn't exactly sequel but here you can
actually talk to it and just sort of ask
it iteratively maybe refine what you're
looking for
um change the way things are ranked the
same way you would in email you know
where you asked for something and then
you're like oh wait can we filter that
um can we you know do something else
with that and just make that whole
experience very uh very iterative
and importantly you also aren't stuck in
one spot in the sense that if you need
to change the topic if you need to ask
about something else maybe you're asking
about products here
and then that Sparks something about
marketing channels so maybe you want to
okay let's change the topic yeah I need
to know about you know acquisition and
different marketing channels now
um You can actually just do that because
dllm doesn't care that your previous
question was you know in the orderlines
table and your new question is in the
you know marketing spend table that's
irrelevant to it it has that semantic
layer knowledge so it's able to actually
go and figure out where that new query
where that new context needs to come
from
so you're able to change the topic as
well again similar to an email thread
that all these end users are more than
familiar with
so
what does this mean for data scientists
what does this mean for
um what you know our jobs as data
scientists will look like
and so I think to answer that question
we've got to go back to our big view of
self-serve so when we're looking at
self-serve if what I'm talking about is
you know the progression then you've got
these these view these olap dashboards
you've got the interactivity of these
dashboards you've got the ability to
maybe go One Step Beyond that dashboard
and then with llms you've got the
ability to basically just ask a question
and if it's in this semantic layer if
your business has context on it you're
able to answer it so then you know what
does that mean where does that put data
scientists and
um I think it's good
so the end result I think of how that
affects data scientists work is that
teams will spend more time building
these semantic layers because the value
of having that llm interface is so great
that you will spend more time building
these semantic layers doing these you
know definitions making sure that when
the model goes to execute a join it's
executing it correctly it's calculating
metrics correctly you just so to spend
more time
building these semantic layers
um but you'll also spend a lot more time
on the complicated things that you
actually need your education for
a lot of data science work now and I see
this in friends that ask me about
getting into a data science sort of
field is that you're going to go and
learn scikit learn and then you're going
to get a job and you're going to just
write SQL that's what a lot of like
getting into data science actually looks
for people who are trying to make a
career switch I think with the Advent of
llms and their combination with the
semantic layer being able to make a lot
of that you know just
sequel monkey work basically go away is
I'm going to open up the work for you to
be able to do complex statistical things
you know build custom models that are
internal to your company and actually
actually use the education that you have
and the skills that you have as a data
scientist
um and then that's also going to be less
time spent asking these answering these
sort of ad hoc questions
where you know people are just asking
you to effectively write SQL for them
that those questions will still exist to
some extent but for a large part for the
for the most part will go away
and that work will take place you know
sort of where it does now like most of
that is in code most of that is in you
know Jupiter or a hex or a something
like that
um and I think there's a sense in which
a lot of this work doesn't really ever
get automated away like a lot of what
you do as a data scientist is very very
specific to a company and has a ton of
nuance in it and you really do need your
education to be able to
um do those kinds of things to be able
to do that level of work and that's the
work that will become more valuable and
thankfully the work that you'll be
spending more time doing because it's
also more fun than just answering ad hoc
SQL questions so
um so I'll just close with
this is uh this is a really exciting
future that data scientists get to work
on stuff that their education makes them
uniquely qualified for they get to add
more value to the business as a result
that they're working on things that
um that they're better at and are more
valuable and this combination of llms
and the semantic layer makes a lot of
what's grindy and what's tough about the
data science job just
evaporate in the sense that end users
are able to get a better experience
they're able to get answers faster they
don't all feel like they're on the
bottom of your ever lengthening queue
and it's really a better a better
outcome for everybody so it's a future
I'm I'm really excited about
foreign